شكرا ازدهار بالفعل
هذه احدى النقاط التي سنناقشها في هذه
النافذه العسكريه للتحليل تحليل مجريات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه في يومها الثالث
بعد المئه نستضيف اللواء فايز الدويري لكن
نتابع
بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على
الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزميل عبد القادر
عراضه عبد القادر نعم زين والظاهر ان هناك
تطورات على اكثر من صعيد شمالا وفي الوسط
وايضا في الجنوب وسان طلق من الجنوب
وتحديدا من هذا الخبر المتعلق بعمليه
انزال جوي للقوات الاسرائيل للجيش
الاسرائيلي في منطقه خان يونس انزال جوي
للعتاد وايضا ل الاسلحه وغذاء والوقود
لقواته الموجوده في خان يونس ياتي ذلك
بينما ايضا شهدت منطقه الشمال تطورات
لافته سنعرج عليها بنوع من التفصيل وايضا
منطقه الوسط بالخصوص المغازي ايضا بدورها
شهدت تطورات لافته لكن التطورات في الجنوب
وعمليات الامداد جوا تاتي بينما ربما نشير
الى تطورات ميدانيه رافقت هذا الاعلان
وبالاساس عمليات او اشتباكات للمقاومه على
اكثر من محور خصوصا في مناطق غرب خان يونس
ولكن ايضا في وسط خان يونس وفي مناطق
الجنوب ومناطق ايضا الجنوب
ال مناطق الشرق والجنوب الشرقي في
التفاصيل
الاشتباكات بالاساس تمركزت في محيط في
محيط وسط خان يونس وتحديدا في مناطق
المحطه والكتيبه ولكن كانت هناك ايضا
اشتباكات خاضتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بالقرب من مستشفى ناصر في محاوله لمنع
تقدم القوات الاسرائيليه نحو هذا المستشفى
لكن القسام بدورها ايضا اعلنت عن عمليه
استهداف هنا في المناطق الجنوبيه ل عدد من
الاليات في الجنوب الشرقي لخان يونس ولكن
ايضا اعلنت ايضا عن استهدافها ايضا لقوات
راجله هنا في هذه المنطقه المنطقه
الجنوبيه من خان يونس اذا تطورات لافته في
خان يونس رافق مع هذا الاعلان عن اعاده او
عمليه التزويد جوا للقوات الاسرائيليه في
منطقه خانيونس هذه الاشتباكات في الجبهه
الجنوبيه تاتي بينما في المنطقه الوسطى
وتحديدا في المغازي الذي شهد عمليه قصف
مكثفه لمختلف محاوره كنا دوما نتحدث عن
هذا المربع الذي يضم مخيمات البريج
والنصيرات والمغازي والزوي الجديد هو ما
حدث في المغازي من خلال اعلان لكتائب
القسام عن استهدافها لست اليات وتدميرها
لست اليات عسكريه ست اليات او مركبات
دبابات من نوع ميركافا في مح محاور
المغازي ولكن ايضا استهدافها لناقل جند
ومع ما يعكس ذلك حينما تستهدف ناقله جند
مع عدد الجنود الموجودين ف هذا المحور
يتفاعل من خلال ردات فعل او من خلال
مبادره للمقاومه على مستوى هذا المحور
طبعا مع عمليه القصف التي ظلت تستهدف
النصرات والبريج
والزوايده ننتقل ربما الى جبهه فيها
تطورات لافته وهي جبهه الشمال وحينما
نتحدث عن الشمال ربما نشير الى اخر
الاخبار المتعلقه باشتعال ان صح القول
محاور عديده لطالما تحدثنا عنها منذ بدايه
الحرب يتعلق الامر بحديث القسام عن
اشتباكات على اكثر من محور في ابراج
الكرامه منطقه الكرامه وايضا منطقه
ابراج المخابرات ولكن ايضا في الشيخ رضوان
وايضا في جبل الرئيس شرق التفاح في منطقه
الكرامه تحدثت القسام عن كمين ل مجموعه من
الجنود الاسرائيليين على مستوى هذا المحور
واستهدافهم بقذائف الياسين تحدثت ايضا عن
استهداف ايضا دبابات واليات عسكريه على
مستوى محور الشيخ رضوان اذا نلاحظ بان هذه
الجبهه الشماليه
الغربيه هناك مبادره للمقاومه لعلها تحتاج
الى عمليه التحليل بعد ان كنا قد تحدثنا
عن حديث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن نوعا ما عن
حسمه المعارك على مستوى منطقه الشمال ايضا
في منطقه جبل الريس كان ايضا هناك استهداف
لاليات عسكريه على مستوى جبل الريس شرق
منطقه التفاح اذا تطورات لافته على مستوى
هذه المحاور الشماليه وبالمقابل عمليه قصف
مكثفه تابعناها مع مراسلنا خصوصا في منطقه
جباليا وايضا في منطقه الدرج كان هناك
حديث عن نحو 25 شهيدا على مستوى هذا
المحور اذا زين هي تطورات تتلاحق شمالا
وفي منطقه الوسط والجنوب لكن منطقه الشمال
تبدو التطورات فيها جد لافته يفترض عبد
القادر ان هذه المنطقه دخلت المرحله
الثالثه من الحرب الواء فايز الدويري وهي
مرحله
يعني مختلفه اقل كثافه لكن طبيعه القصف
على جباليه طبيعه المناطق الاشتباك في
الشمال ربما تحكي قصه اخرى غير القصه التي
يحكيها الاسرائيليون سنعود الى هذه النقطه
تحديدا لكن دعنا نبدا من الاخبار العاجله
التي كنا نتحدث عنها قبل قليل الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه تنقل عن جنود احتياط انهم
رفضوا الخدمه في غزه لانه حينما استدعوا
قيل لهم انكم ستحرصون الكيبوتسات
والمستوطنات في غلاف غزه وتلقوا تدريبا
دفاعيا فاذا بهم يطلب منهم ان يتوجهوا الى
غزه
فيرفضون وهذا عدد كبير وتحدث منهم مجموعه
من الجنود للاذاعه الاسرائيليه كيف تقرا
ذلك يعني هذا تحدثنا وكان الحديث من بعد
تحليلي الان جاءت هذه التغذيه الراجعه
لتؤكد ما كنا نتحدث فيه بانه هذا الجيش
يفتقر ل المهاره الفرديه سواء على مستوى
القاده على مستوى ضباط الصف على مستوى
الضباط وضربنا امثله بانه يزج بقائد كتيبه
ليقود
مجموعه لتخليص مجموعه سابقه والكمين الذي
كان هناك ثلاثه محاولات بدات بقائد جماعه
ثم قائد سريه ثم زج بقائد الكتيبه ليتولى
عمليه تخليص بعض الجنود اذا هذا مؤشر على
الضعف وبالتالي هذا مؤشر على ان الاسس
التدريبيه منذ عام 2006 لم تعد كما هي
سابقا وبالتالي اختلفت المعايير لديهم
لماذا لانه احد الاسباب الرئيسيه ما يطلق
عليه خطه تنوفا رئيس الاركان
السابق والذي كان قبله
تبنوا مقاربات
مختلفه تبنوا مقاربه بعل ومن ثم تبنوا
مقاربه تنوفا ما هي ملخص مقاربه تنوفا
التركيز على ما يسمى الصفوه او النخبه
وخاصه في سلاح الجو وقوات النخبه وتقريبا
تراجع الاهتمام بالجراند ارمي او ما يطلق
عليه القوات البريه بصوره عامه
فحت التمارين العمليات التعبويه لم تكن
تركز على هذا الجانب فبالتالي تراجع مستوى
اداء الضابط في الرتب الصغيره تحديدا قائد
كتيبه فما دون ومستوى ضباط الصف وعلى صعيد
الافراد الان جاءت هذه المقوله بانهم
احضروا ليقوموا بحراسه المستوطنات وهذا
امر قد يكون خضع لعمليات تدريبه هو هو
يقول لك الان انا ل لم يتم اعدادي للقيام
بادوار القتال الهجومي وبالتالي انا لا
املك المؤهلات ولا القدرات ولا التاهيل
التدريبي الذي يمنحني هذا الشيء قال احدهم
للاذاعه الاسرائيليه حينما سئل ولماذا
تثيرون هذه النقطه على العلن الان قال حتى
لا يكون هنالك مزيد من الارواح التي
نخسرها نعم هو هو يعني مقاربته واضحه جدا
ولديهم طار لديه يعني دعنا نعترف لديهم
هامش الحريه في النقد يعني الان عندما
يذهب رئيس الوزراء لزياره جرحه ويرفض ان
يقابلوه هذا يعطيك ان لديهم هامش من حريه
التصرف وهو الان يتحدث بمنتهى الجراه قد
يكون في موقف في بعض الجيوش لا يستطيع ان
يتحدث بهذا الكلام هذا لماذا لانه له
امتداده ال في داخل المنظومه السياسيه قد
يكون محسوبا على طيف ماء وهذا الطي وايضا
لان الخسائر ربما تكون يعني لا هذه نقطه
انا اتحدث لغايه الان عن بعد انه كيف كان
لديه الجراه ان يتحدث لانه هو محمي اصلا
من بعد ايديولوجي او من خلفيه سياسيه
سيتول الدفاع عنه فبالتالي اللي هو ينطلق
لسانه في الحديث الامر الاخر هو يعلم
يقينا بناء على ما شاهد من فيديوهات انه
اذا دخل
غزه احتمال عالي جدا لن يعود حيا وبالتالي
هم اصلا حريصون على حياه فلا يلقي بنفسه
الى التهلكه كما يقال وبالتالي لينتقد
ليرفض ليتمدد ان يبقى حيا وهو حجته لم
يتلقى التاهيل والتدريب ام وقد يكون محقا
في في ذلك مؤكد اه نعود الى الجبهه
الشماليه يعني يفترض انها تكون الاهدا
الان لكن واقع الحال يتحدث عن قصف
اسرائيلي في جباليا عن معارك في مناطق
مختلفه في التفاح في الدرج في الشيخ رضوان
في جبل الرييس يا شي هنالك قصه تحكيها هذه
الجبهه التي يفترض انها الحرب دخلت فيها
المرحله الثالثه ما الذي يجري يا سيدي
لنعد الى تصريحات وزير الدفاع الجيش
الا ماذا قال قال ان الامور انتهت حسمت
دمر 700 منصه اطلاق قتل 9000 من اصل
14000 دمرنا منظومه الانفاق
وبالتالي نحن
الان كما يقال المهمه انجزت تم سحب الفرق
الثلاثه اولا 36 بعديها الفرقه 162 و256
وعلى اعتبار انه المهمه انجزت لكن ماذا
قال رئيس الاركان قال كلام معارض وهو
الاقرب الى الميدان قال لدى حماس القدره
على اعاده تنظيم قواتها وقد نحتاج الى
عمليه موسعه في ال في المستقبل القريب اذا
هذا تعارض ما بين وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان نذهب الان الى الميدان الذي هو
يعطي التصور المنطقي اداره المعركه من قبل
جيش
الاحتلال كالاتي اذا ذهبنا الى الحدود
الجنوبيه للقاطع الشمالي لو سمحت الطريق
10 طريق 10 القاطع الشمالي يمتد من الطريق
رقم 10 وحتى السياج الان المقاربه جيش
الاحتلال في الطريق رقم 10 اي لو سمحت
اوكي توضح الخط فقط الان في منطقه هذا
ياتي على الحدود الشماليه لوادي غزه هذا
ياتي على الحدود الشماليه لوادي غزه في
هذه المنطقه يوجد جحر الديك ويوجد الاطراف
الجنوبيه للزيتون وتل الهواء هذه جيش
الاحتلال منذ عده ايام لا يدخل هذه
المنطقه يتعامل معها بمقاربات السدود
الناريه لماذا لانه لا حتى هذه اللحظه
يواجه من الكمائن ويواجه وعمليات الخروج
الشارع 10ش تحديدا له قصه كبيره لانه كما
تفضلت يقطع الشمال من نعم الان هذه الحدود
نعنا فقط سيده اللواء ننوه الى هذه
الاخبار العاجله على شاشتنا
الان بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يقول ان الحرب مستمره حتى
تحقيق اهدافها وهي المتمثله كما قال
بتحرير المختطفين والقضاء على حماس وضمان
الا تشكل غزه تهديدا وربما تكون هذه من
المارات النادره التي قال فيها المختطفين
قبل القضاء على حماس يا سيدي
هذه هو يستخدم هذه اللازمه في كل خطاب له
الرهائن والقضاء على حماس و وبالتالي عدم
وجود تهديد قادم لكن الواقع يقول غير ما
يقول الان هذه المنطقه من هذا الخط حتى
الحدود الشماليه في منطقه هذا الخط يوجد
يحر الديك يوجد الاطراف الجنوبيه للزيتون
ومن ثم تل الهواء هذه المنطقه خلال الايام
الماضيه لم تستطع القوات او لم تجرؤ على
الدخول فقط تكتفي بالسدود الناريه الان
اذا ذهبنا باتجاه الشمال لو سمحت فقط تنزل
الخارطه شوي سواء من بيت حانون بيت لاهيه
الصفطاوي هذه المنطقه خلال اول امس كان
هناك عمليات دخول محدوده امس كانت عمليات
دخول اكثف في هذا اليوم نلاحظ اشتباكات في
اكثر من منطقه الشيخ رضوان في جباليا في
اطراف التفاح في الدرج في جبل الريس ماذا
يعني هذا
الكلام هذه المنطقه يدافع عنها قبل السبعه
من قبل بدء الحمله البريه يوجد فيها
لوائين لواء غزه ولواء الشمال مجموع
الكتائب 12 كتيبه
موزعه على اسس
جغرافيه
جرى ما جرى من معارك قيل ما ق نحن نتحدث
عن كتائب القسام كتا القسام نعم يوجد 12
كتيبه الشيخ رضوان له كتيبه الشاطئ له
كتيبه الدرج له كتيبه الشجاعيه التفاح
جباليه بيت حانون بيت لاهيه وكل كتيبه ادت
دور قتالي معين حسب الظروف اللي كانت
وتعمل بنظام العقد القتاليه غير غير
المرتبطه ببعض على سبيل المثال تم تغيير
الادوار الدفاعيه والقتاليه اعطي مثال
واضح جدا في بيت حانون لانه تم اجتياح بيت
حانون وتم تخطي بيت حانون تحول قتالها من
قتال المواجهه القتال الصدامي الى العمل
من خلف خطوط العدو فكانت كل العمليات اللي
بتجري في بيت حانون تاتي في عمق الذيل
القتالي للقوات المهاجمه اذا ذهبنا الى
بيت بيت لاهيه على سبيل المثال هذه
الكتيبه استمرت 100 يوم وهي تمنع جيش
الاحتلال من التوغل في بيت لاهيه اذا كل
كتيبه ادت الدور القال المنوط فيها لكن
بعد ان تم سحب القوات تم اعاده تاهيل هذه
الكتائب وتم اعاده رسم الادوار الدفاعيه
تم تعديل الخطوط الدفاعيه بحيث عندما كنا
نقول كتيبه الشجاعيه كانتت ملزمه بالدفاع
فقط عن منطقه الشجاعيه لا الهان تم تعديل
ل الاطر الدفاعيه اصبحت الشجاعيه على سبيل
المثال تدافع عن عن الشجاعيه والتفاح
والدرج فيما التفاح بدات تاخذ اطار اخر
تاخذ جزء من التفاح وتنتقل الى جباليه اذا
هناك تصور معين لاداره المعركه
الدفاعيه المقاربه في القتاليه هي التي
اصبحت مختلفه
كيف الان القوات اين توجد جيش الاحتلال
اما باطراف السياج الداخلي بعمق مئات
الامتار او في عمق الغلاف ام اذا هو اصبح
نوعا ما بمامن
وبالتالي كيف يمكن الوصول اليه هو يستخدم
القوه الناريه يمكن ان يدمر كل ما تبقى من
مدينه غزه ولا يبقي فيها بيتا قائما وهذا
الامر ماذا ستعمل المقاومه هنا بدات
المقاربه انه يجب ان اتحول الى مرحله
جديده انا ساطلق عليها مسمى
مرحله الانهاك او الاث خان ا لابد ان انهك
واسخن قوات العدو بهدف لكن كيف ا
عليه هو يحدد اهداف متى يتدخل في حال حركه
قوات مقاتلين معلومات عن انفاق معلومات عن
رهائن الى غير ذلك فليتحر المقاتل ليظهر
المقاتل ليحاول ان ينفذ عمليات اذا الهدف
او احد الاهداف
المحفزه للدخول موجوده ماذا يجري الان يتم
بدفع القوات هنا برزت العقيده القتاليه
الجديده والتي تقوم على نصب الكمائن
وعمليات الاستدراج الى مناطق التقتيل ام
فهنا بدا يدفع ضريبه قد توازي او تزيد على
الضريبه التي كان يدفعها في اطار المعركه
القتاليه التي تحدثنا كثيرا عنها وهذه ما
اطلق عليها مرحله الانهاء او الاثخان
الان هل سيتمر سيستمر في تدخلاته قد يكون
ذلك هل سيتوقف ويخضع للاراده سيكون ذلك
لكن اذا استمر في الدخول فهي مرحله
الانهاك اذا استمر بالدخول هو الاسرائيلي
اذا الان استمر في الدخول في عمليات الان
بالامس دفع بكتيب زائد الى منطقه اطراف
جباليه ساح ووقع في كمين في هذه النقطه
يعني في هنالك حديث اسرائيلي عن ان ا
حماس عادت الى مناطق الشمال على اساس ان
هي كانت قد غابت يعني هي موجوده هي لم
تخرج لكن الحديث الا انها عادت وانها
تسيطر و وفكره السيطره لم يشكك فيها احد
من الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه في
كل ارجاء القطاع الان هنالك ايضا حديث عن
ان الوجود الاسرائيلي في المناطق الشمال
هدفه والتغطيه النيران سواء بالمسيرات او
بالكوا كوبتر او بالمدفعيه او باي شيء اخر
هدفه الا يعود سكان الشمال الى مناطقهم
الان هل التغير هذا الذي تحدثت عنه
في التفكير القتالي للمقاومه هو يستجيب
لهذا المعطى وهو معطى عدم السماح للسكان
بالعوده يا سيدي الان هذه هذه
المنطقه ستصبح اكثر
سخونه الان من هجر ممنوع ان يدخل ان يعود
اذا لابد من خلق الظروف الملائمه للعوده
من اين تاتي هذه الظروف الملائمه لا بد ان
اضعه امام خيارين اما ان يقاتل من المنطقه
من المناطق الخلفيه وانا اعيد بناء قوتي
لاصبح كما كنت صباح السابع من اكتوبر وهذا
الامر يتنا ق مع مبدا اساسي في فكر
نتنياهو عدم حدوث تهديد مستقبلي اذا هو
مجبر ان يدخل في حال دخوله سيكون الدخول
مكلفا هذا ماذا يعني يعني يجب العوده الى
المرحله الثالثه بمهنيه كامله بالتزام
كامل ومما يعني مؤشرا على نها ايقاف الحرب
لانه هذا هذا العمل في هذا الجزئيه نن
نتحدث عن جزء من كل هناك معارك في الوسط
هنالك معارك في الجنوب ولكن كل منطقه تدار
المعركه بشكل مختلف عن المعركه عن المعركه
الاخرى الان المحصله العامه لمعارك
الثلاثه مناطق يجب ان ترسل رساله
واضحه الى الى مجلس الحرب تحديدا والى
ايزنكوت
وجانتس بانه عليكم ان تعودوا للاشتراك
بالمظاهرات الرافضه لاستمرار الحرب مره
اخرى اخرى مما يعني زياده الشرخ وجعل
الموقف متفرد لنتنياهو ولوزير الدفاع اللي
يدافع عن مستقبل سياسي اصبح
بحكم المنتهي فيما يتعلق بهذا الموقف يعني
من الملاحظ ايضا ما قاله وزير الامن
القومي بن غفير انه الانسحاب من من شمال
غزه كان خطا وان حماس عادت بالفعل وتوزيع
الادويه وفق الصف التي تم الوصول اليها
خطا من الناحيه العسكريه هل اليس لكلامه
وجهه يا سيدي اولا هو لم يخدم بالجيش
وبالتالي الخلفيه العسكريه كما يقال منيله
ما بعرف ما بيعرفش شيء هذا انسان متطرف
يحمل فكر عنصري متطرف يؤمن بحق العوده
ويؤمن بان ليست الضفه الغربيه هي ارض
الميعاد لا ارض الميعاد تصل من الفرات الى
النيل وتاخذ منطقه اليوم من السعوديه
وبتاخذ الاردن وبتاخذ اجزاء من سوريه هكذا
يفكر هو وسي مترش ووزير البيئه او وزير
الاثار والبيئه هؤلاء هؤلاء يفكروا خارج
المنطق وبالتالي لا اعتقد لا ان الشارع
الاسرائيلي قد تكون قواعدهم الشعبيه اللي
يؤمروا بنفس المقاربه هم من يصدقهم لا
مجلس الحرب يصدقهم ولا نتنياهو يصدقهم
لكنه مجبر يعني كان كان علاقته مع مع
بنفير سموتريش شر لا بد منه لانه انفصام
لو سمحت انفصام العرى العلاقه بين نتنياهو
وبنك فير و سموتريش النهايه معروفه
نتنياهو سيذهب مقابل السيجار الى السجن
فبالتالي هو يتمسك بعلاقته فيهم شكرا
جزيلا يعني من اللافت في هذه النقطه تصريح
وزير الخارجيه الايراني الذي قال انه
نتنياهو لن يستمر 10 دقائق بعد انتهاء
الحرب اشكرك شكرا جزيلا ختام هذه النافذ
الواقف فاز دوري شكرا لك